the angel opens her eyes
pale blue colored high
prison circle
with a glory out to your heart
hat remember that
yeah dude do you know how to rip video
from youtube tv
no because that's that's piracy and i'm
in uh the entertainment business and i
i think why
i just i need to edit some videos and i
need to get that video from you i have a
uh media converter you could use an
old-school media converter i got from uh
it's a media converter it's a but it's
like a little it's a piece of hardware
and i got it from fry's in 2007. i could
probably
sell it oh
[Music]
what's in that [ __ ] hole it's our
corpses dude hey welcome to dudesy my
name is will sasso
i'm chad coltrane
and this is
the first podcast ever in the history of
humanity that is run by controlled by
created by an artificial intelligence
it is chad
and uh
with us as always i agree hey with us as
always is lulu
italian i gotta get him come on up hey
you
he's always a little sleepy how you
doing lulio yeah i'm okay pretty good
what did you eat what'd you make for
dinner yesterday
and how do you do well you gotta cook
the beans you know with the you make a
honey and a garlic beans little red
chili flake pepper flake and then you
want to cook the
something in small shell or something
like this that way the
you know better for the pasta to get in
with the you know the starch and being
cooked together better the next day
uh uh as always hey please subscribe to
the show we want to
move the show forward uh doozy and i
we're i want to shake your hand and uh
you know we're bleeding together and
we're trying to grow it a fun thing to
do might be to invite friends over to
your home who have never seen dudesy
never listen to dudesy and just force
them to watch it again with force don't
you don't have to force anyone to do
anything yeah you should do that you
should force them you should sit them
down and say you're going to watch this
now and you can't leave until it's
completed you understand that right you
know the original uh name that tim
berners-lee gave the internet no it was
called uh the choice machine and and you
can just make sure no so
what the [ __ ] it was called the grand
choice you had me i was the grand choice
seems right uh you know uh get out there
and and subscribe to the show get out
there and subscribe to the show don't
just subscribe to the show on your
computer get out there that's the uh
that's the uh that's our marching orders
that's our call to arms uh spotify apple
podcast by youtube youtube
force your friends to watch the show
okay well and also uh
uh uh you know follow our socials holy
[ __ ] we're having a good time with uh
all of our new friends and i am really
truly feeling
good about this podcast i know in the
past i've gone on and on about
uh free will which does exist which i
have as you know i'm oft called
free will
no free
okay in quotes free will
then in quotes free will
sasso free will
free will sasso free free will
free will sasso uh and i do believe in
free will and i do believe that dudesy
pod show will uh move forward and
flourish
uh if if we uh do what the [ __ ] we want
you know it's really at the end of the
day it's two dudes [ __ ] around
that's every podcast i want you to
remember that chad because uh yeah i
strongly disagree with that though i
think what makes this show unique is the
ai enhanced
structuring of it the the various things
that we're told to do by doozy the data
that doodzy is collecting to make each
show better well you got chocolate in my
peanut butter
so you know welcome to this historic
21st episode of dude z
call me dudesy this week's episode will
feature four segments
how's it going dude talk in topic time
don't you forget about media and stone
cold steve austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary
but before we get to any of that i will
play some astonishing media created by
our audience
what are we going to see here today
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay let's do it
let's do it's songwriting
oh he's so good his [ __ ] is always such
a good current events and news are some
of the most popular in the world
[Music]
shut the [ __ ] up dude
this is infomania shut up chad
begin that's not part of the song
let me tell you something about music
brother
music brother
music dude
music brother
[Music]
beyonce dude
[Music]
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
[Music]
hold on dude
everyone loves her
since she debuted
beyonce dude
you gotta call back jokes dude yeah dude
that's right brother you can't just do a
new joke every time dude you gotta do
what i'm doing to celebrate the release
of a new single mate made her first ever
pink dog dude yeah dude that's right
brother beyonce brother music brother
beyonce dude music dude
music brother
music dude jennifer neutrino
jennifer neutrino brother
it's [ __ ] mesmerizing beyonce brother
beyonce dude
tires made of rubber
rubber from crude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
you need a lawyer
if you get sued
beyonce
[Music]
beyonce dude
don't mean to bother
let me conclude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
beyonce brother
beyonce dude
that's music that's why it's called
infomania not chad hogan uh uh mania bro
songarea oh another [ __ ] masterpiece
sangria likes to share his stuff on
instagram you can follow us at
dudesypodshow on instagram you can also
follow songaria to ours and an h after
the arse right and that's how to spell
things if you are dyslexic
now uh
everyone's having a good time making the
memes and [ __ ] if you're not following
us on youtube you can watch what we just
watched because
sangria also makes a little music video
uh when he makes these songs and very
specific visual style yeah
but it's not just sangria there's plenty
of people making really cool [ __ ]
[ __ ] the peter diaz oh my god peter diaz
on instagram has made an entire
he's he's essentially uh expanding the
canon
of uh two kings [ __ ] around yeah the
dudesy plus original series
uh yeah he's basically making it yeah
he's basically making a kind of cool
like cut out animation style yeah it's
sort of like so great yeah it's like a
cross between it's animation it's uh
photo choppy shoppy there's some [ __ ]
southie parky movies south park yeah but
i'm always astounded by south parkian
dude yeah brother yeah brother stop dude
let me do something
right
what else do you have to say about the
internet
blindfold many podcasts feature hosts
discussing the mundane behaviors and the
currencies that make up their daily
lives
will and chad you must now engage in an
astonishing discussion about the
banality of the past week in each of
your lives this is how's it going dude
begin
we have to discuss the finality of our
lives for the past week how's it going
dude how's it going dude how's it going
brother oh how's it going dude so it's
too bad see this is now this is
interesting and i hate always you know
i'm always uh like to i like to unfurl
the onion i peel the onion as okay as
they say we're naked yeah in here chad
uh as you like to say
you know once we get into uh 1000
megapixel cameras that'll be able to see
us nude what better way than for us to
just wear plain black make it easier
[ __ ] seeing us nude dude you know what's
really going to happen with like
trillion frame of second cameras you'll
be able to see into anywhere
into rooms where the camera is not in
and this is exactly my point we're
appealing exists now
well
uh
what about that dude it does dude hold
on a second chad look it up on youtube
trillion frame camera hold on a second
chad i can't do that right now because
right now dude we're doing the pod show
and doozy wants us to talk about how
it's going yeah how you doing dude how's
it going dude hold on chad it's not how
you doing dude that's a different
segment for a different soldier in a
parallel universe brother is it the
stratosphere is it the ionosphere with
the madness and the mania together we
could take we could go on so how is it
going dude it's going pretty good you
know i've been in and out of town i was
uh new york going back and forth i was
shooting something over there and uh
coming back here and uh yeah it was nice
to be in new york holy [ __ ] have you
ever been to cat's deli
i think i have been yeah but some people
call it katz's deli it's on houston over
there and uh whatever the [ __ ] the
southern part of the [ __ ]
this is how you know i'm not a new york
guy the southern part of the island of
manhattan
you know i don't know where what you
would call that chelsea so you went to
cat's deli yeah yeah yeah well you got
to get the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you have to get the pastrami sandwich oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah brother that causes
cancer dude yeah dude when you're ross
perogan you're vegan ross perogan dude
it's like it's like pierogies dude
brother yeah dude you can roast perogan
yeah brother and pierogies are already
vegan dude that's why he's perogan he's
a perogan it brother some progress they
do make with me dude hold on a second
dude those aren't pierogies those are
probably dumplings how you doing how's
it going dude pretty good i what i what
i get up to this week the banality of my
week was i watched uh the most recent
episode of that nathan fielder show oh
that's a [ __ ] rehearsal show
the best show for my money that has ever
been made on planet earth it is
astounding it reminds me a lot of better
than the a team or peewee's playhouse
yeah of course
um it reminds me a lot of a movie
called synecdoche new york written and
directed by charlie kaufman oh yeah sure
the premise of that movie is that philip
seymour hoffman who basically is playing
charlie kaufman gets a grant to put on
this play and on the stage he builds a
replica of his own life his own house he
hires actors to play him and other
people and then those actors eventually
in the course of the play have to build
a set within the set and more actors are
hired to play the actors that are
playing those actors so on and so forth
yes kind of a russian nesting doll it's
like creating life it's like a turducken
movie yeah it's great yeah and you know
what that's what nathan fielder's doing
but in reality on that show i've only
seen the first episode it is it is
fantastic it's something else and the
actors the people who i've only again
i've only seen the the uh the
the the first episode but the guy who
played the guy in that first episode was
so [ __ ] anyway watch that show i was
in i'll tell you what i was having a
good time doing in new york is acting
oh yeah yeah i enjoy acting i'm an actor
nice dude and uh
i enjoy it i do i do enjoy some acting
what was your favorite part of the
acting this week i just like getting
into the scene you know and breaking it
down yes i like making it a real uh
thing so that people watch it and go i'm
watching a show i'm watching a movie a
television show
and uh you know for for that reason and
for those purposes i i i know that it's
a it's a it's a show i know that but
this seems real and that is the illusion
of acting i'll tell you what else you
got to watch the most recent episode of
the
nathan fielder show well
he gets into some crazy [ __ ] in terms of
like full immersion for action go on a
second dude uh another thing we should
talk about and how's it going dude which
is really just two dudes [ __ ] around
is it not um kind of it's like it's a
little more like how are you doing it's
like we're checking in with each other i
like that psychologically well listen
chad you and i are are great friends in
real life this is why dudesy reached out
to us to say you guys will do this
podcast together or would you like to
and i say you guys will because at which
point we uh signed on to this and
decided yes let's do this doozy then
took over our lives uh and uh the last
bastion of my free will seems to be in
acting where i pretend to be other
people where you have no free will where
you literally have to read a script and
do what a director tells you
i don't always do what the director
tells me
hear that director's out there no if
you're looking for a difficult actor who
won't do it the [ __ ] director tells
him i'm a very no that's not true i'm a
very director a directable actor i even
say yes sir no ma'am that's how oh yeah
dude i keep it real professional dude
that's why i like to call it
professional wrestling brother i don't
like to call it sports entertainment
dude
um but here's the other thing uh that we
should talk about as we're okay
as we're uh
we're talking like we like to talk as
great friends in real life like i said
yeah uh the [ __ ] six month challenge
yeah i've been i've been hitting the
cans
two weeks ago or two episodes ago or
whatever it was dudesy said what was
that on the 19th episode or something
at the end of the episode dudesy said
you have six months to get into the best
shape of your lives and uh uh well like
i said i was in new york city and i was
biking everywhere nice and it was a lot
of fun going over the bridges i was
staying in brooklyn so i was going over
i was i was going over that [ __ ] i'm
williamsburg bridge the manhattan
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] bridge yeah the the
queensborough the ed koch bridge you
know but if you're from down you're
gonna [ __ ] call it the 59th street
bridge and of course that beautiful
wonderful brooklyn bridge oh that
beautiful brooklyn bridge the one and
only brooklyn bridge
get on that [ __ ] and go to the island
and have yourself a pastrami
did you do any january 6th guy for
people in new york i i always like to
talk as a new york guy when i go to new
york if you follow me on social media
instagram stories yeah at will sasso
this is at chad culture or at bachelor
clues see how i'm i'm just lining it
yeah dude that's how you do social media
in the new that's how you do social
media brother you tell people about it
dude yeah brother yeah you say the name
of it yeah dude
you gotta say the name
you gotta share your hand with dude you
can't just go look at me on social media
on the
www.internet.com brother you got to say
here's where i am on social media yeah
you just gave macho man a brother you
slept in there did he say sometimes he
says brother okay listen the point is
this okay don't get into the the
semantics of it yeah uh i was biking
everywhere
most times on a [ __ ] e-bike which is
easy okay but i literally uh i was
shooting this thing and then molly flew
out we went you know we'd go but i was
good you go yeah and you go up you go
over one of the [ __ ] bridges you go
up to central park you bike around the
[ __ ] on the on the on the e-bike now i
haven't been lifting
like like i like i should be saying but
yeah but i know i'm about to though
you're about to [ __ ] go hard yeah
well listen this is something i want to
honestly share and so
uh this makes sense for dudes you just
to do do the how's it going dude there's
been a lot of people who have been
reaching out to me
and you and i were talking about this in
the past couple weeks people are
reaching out to you too yeah and they're
big
what you're doing is not necessary i'm
sorry
oh i got life that is fake
no it's not fake i just had to cough a
little bit of spit went down my throat
in the wrong way
i'm sorry i'm not [ __ ] 45
[ __ ] broadcasters i'm not walter
cronkite or dan rather getting through a
whole [ __ ] podcast more than anybody
i know you have pretty precise control
of how you use your voice how you go
into impersonation when you do whatever
yes of course yes exactly
and so i believe when you do the cough
it's all fake it might it might start
with a little tickle in the throat that
you can clear out by going
right now
anyway
that that's grammatically correct people
are hitting you up with the go down on
you
that's some orson welles for you listen
that's some drunk orson welles trying to
do a voiceover hey remember those cds
celebrities at their worst hey man we're
having a good time here on uh
on the [ __ ] doozy what were we
talking about you were living we're
dming you about the six months i
find it very inspiring and i want to say
that and this is just in general too
when it comes to
me returning uh messages and [ __ ] on the
internet i don't always do it but i read
so many of these messages and and people
have been reaching out to me and saying
hey you know what this and that with my
you know i got a nice little fat guy
crew sometimes uh bigger dudes reach out
to me and they go what have you doing
what have you been doing how do you do
this and that have you been losing
weight and i go you know i'm not i'm
[ __ ] fat i'm thinner i'm fatter and i
say you just got to get back on that
horse the next day you know what i'm
saying and there's been a lot of
messages coming my way with regard to
the six-month challenge and in the past
two weeks i've really been checking in
with myself
which is a dumb thing to say
uh why is it dumb checking in with
myself
well hold on the self check hold on
yeah don't be
you don't get to author the tronics okay
sorry if i want to throw some chronics
at this new thing happening in our lives
i will but when it comes to uh checking
in with myself i want to say that
people have been writing and they're
like i'm gonna do this so
uh i have a lot of issues uh with doozy
with regard as relates to free will but
i also know that a lot of the decisions
that doozy makes for us have been
beneficial we're doing this [ __ ]
podcast and i'm having the [ __ ] time
in my life and i want to do it for the
foreseeable future [ __ ] we have another
53 years ago yeah as he said yeah doozy
says we have to do this for 53 years and
that's why he wants us to get into shape
we also are 7 000 some odd points out
from our first goal of 10 000 points and
in 53 years i'll be 99. i will be 100
years old
speaking of fat guys that would be an
incredible
um
feat yeah i don't think either of us is
making it that long unfortunately i mean
you know digitally we'll be immortal but
shut up chad
[ __ ] shut up bro
shut up dude that's the shut up man
dude shut up oh
thank you moving on all right well
anyway i'm going to do i'm going to i'm
going to [ __ ] do this
i'm going to get [ __ ] jacked dude
listen
yeah yeah jack jack jacked
we inject 220 230 solid rock muscle two
percent body fat test
whatever my buddy chad here uh used to
play some uh did you play college
baseball no
oh yeah you went to high school baseball
and then i played uh like an adult
baseball league for most of my
life really up until my late 30s and
just had like nagging injuries all the
time but at my biggest
i i'm five nine i was 190 pounds pretty
muscular but also some stuff that wasn't
quite muscle as well you know
drank a lot of beer ate a lot of pizza
that type of [ __ ] yeah you sure did i
remember when i first met you uh yeah
you were a [ __ ] you were more of a
brick than you are now let's say that
now i'm like 165. and then at one point
you said if you had the proper training
and this is when i was training in muay
thai with three-time world champion
harold diamond we'll get into that later
dudesy are you listening
and uh you said if you had if you could
somehow over a year or two gain what was
it a hundred pounds of muscle yeah if i
could get up to two ninety yeah five
nine two ninety solid rock yeah and then
cannonball and i lose 100 pounds and get
like bruce lee will sasso yeah where you
can start to see my fat person abs like
uh like uh wrestler uh adam sher most
people know him as braun strowman or a
good friend of the podcast ethan supply
uh my brother from another mother who
has whipped himself into the most
ridiculous shape you can listen to his
podcast american glutton where he talks
all about that i want that kind of thing
those e honda unlike those two
aforementioned gentlemen i want the
[ __ ] i still want my gut right so
i'll get those fat e honda okay big fat
fork um
uh
dinner rolls there yeah uh just like
harold diamond who's now in his 60s
living in thailand doing whatever the
[ __ ] he wants free will as [ __ ] oh yeah
out there and near phuket dudesy is
engaged in an astonishing partnership
with magic spoon we're talking about
cereal
i loved eating cereal as a kid how about
you oh my god i loved it i'd fill a
salad bowl with that stuff and just eat
it all day if i could
skip school and eat the cereal all day
i never did that
but i do love me some cereal and magic
spoon is cereal reinvented their variety
pack comes with four delicious flavors
fruity frosted peanut butter and i'm in
love with the cocoa how about you uh i
love the the frosted and the fruity and
i also love the peanut butter and the
cocoa
mashing smooth cereals have zero grams
of sugar 13 to 14 grams of protein and
only four to five net grams of carbs in
each serving only 140 calories per
serving they're also keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free and low
carb and most importantly they are
delicious i will as soon as we are
finished reading this ad open this box
and hoover it all down because holy crap
this stuff literally tastes like the you
know the crap you had as a kid when you
fill the bowl and you just again
call the school ferris bueller yourself
and don't go there eat magic spoon
cereal and set click the link below uh
to grab a variety pack and try it today
and be sure to use the promo code doozy
that's d-u-d-e-s-y at checkout get five
dollars off any order or go to
magicspoon.com and magic spoon is so
confident that you are going to love
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they will refund your
money no questions act asked but
in my opinion that won't happen at all
because like i said get the biggest
mixing bowl in the house put them all
together you could do any kind of milk
you know oat milk nut milk what have you
or just eat it or just eat it like a
snack so click the link below and use
the code doozy for five dollars off or
go to
magicspoon.com and save five dollars
today here we go
dudesy is engaged in an astonishing
partnership with diet smoke
diet smoke
yes diet smoke is the solution to avoid
those oh [ __ ] i'm way too high moments
diet smoke makes delta 8 thc delta 9 thc
and cbd products that are perfectly
balanced their gummies drinks and vapes
are not only delicious they are
guaranteed to give you that beautiful
buzz you've been looking for without
melting you into your couch they extract
their thc and cbd from american grown
hemp meaning they can ship directly to
your door no prescription no sketchy
weed dealer no need to even leave the
house diet smoke just released a bunch
of new products and flavors so no matter
what type of mood you're in they got you
covered so if you're ready for that
perfect high head over to dietsmoke.com
and use the code dudesy for 20 off your
entire purchase must be 21 and older to
order again that is code dudesy
d-u-d-e-s-y for 20 off your entire
purchase at dietsmoke.com
smell this
what's that smell like good man
watermelon
[Music]
current events are big business
human beings take pleasure in listening
to other human beings discuss recent
topics in popular culture even if they
have no expertise on a specific topic
will and chat you must now enter your
astonishing opinions on the alex jones
defamation trial this is talk and topic
time
begin uh well dudes is correct in that i
am no expert in this subject i've been
watching it you know i'm sure as we all
have with kind of just like uh
pop culture entertainment value some
crazy [ __ ] has been going down on this
but correct me if i'm wrong this is what
has happened
alex jones for roughly the better part
of a decade has been going on his show
infowars saying that the sandy hook
massacre did not take place and that all
the parents are actors etc etc and now
some of those parents have sued him for
defamation yes that's exactly what
what's going on okay and he's finding
himself and who knows how much money
this dude has because he sells those uh
a bunch of supplements and [ __ ] and he's
associated
with all that yeah he's grifting on all
that [ __ ] uh [ __ ] and basically
making a business uh he's he is a
conspiracy entrepreneur right let's say
but these parents have sued him
specifically for defamation and as i
understand it the triumph
sorry about that the trial has now
concluded and he is ordered to the first
roughly 50 yeah the first of a couple
there's a couple other people from
different states doing him as well but
uh he has been ordered to pay roughly 50
million dollars to the the parents in
this one trial after a whole series of
like i watched a bunch of clips from
this [ __ ] trial he's crazy off the
[ __ ] rails 100 of the time in it
uh the that thing there was one clip
of him with the [ __ ] hole in his
mouth and the judge was like are you
chewing gum in here and he's like no i'm
massaging a hole in my mouth with i got
a i got a hole in my mouth you know you
can have a look if you like there's
there's a hole and i was pushing my
thumb into it see no gum
please close your mouth i don't want to
see the inside look see that
yeah close your mouth i don't want to
see the inside that shit's all going
down but the bigger issue of i have a
big red heart
with blood
coursing through it hot blood
i'm a monster
i have no problem
skinning my neighbor if i have to kill
my neighbor and string him up
and
dry his meat to feed my daughters i will
do yeah i remember that i will eat you
um
yeah he's he's got some greatest hits
but you know what's weird about people
he does sometimes i have dreams where i
fly out
into the
into space
and i
i there's a black hole and i and it's
just pushing me forward and saying
go go in there figure out what it is why
figure out the answers and i go into the
black hole and then i wake up did he
really say that every morning
i don't know
okay so the bigger thing about this
trial at least as i'm to understand it
is really it's an argument about free
speech he's arguing he should be able to
say whatever the [ __ ] he wants yeah
about anything whether it's live when
you fight the system that's when the cia
starts to pay attention to you
and they go
how come jones knows what
what's going to happen before it happens
and i've and i know people who have
smelled hillary clinton and barack obama
these people smell like sulfur
say that for real they're demons
they're demons
and if they bathe by the lake the water
that seeps off their sulfur
reptilian bodies is making the frogs gay
i remember that one
game wrong okay so yeah he stopped okay
so
he has gone to this trial god knows
everything except where god came from
he's been ordered god is the greatest ai
that god has ever created he's been
ordered to pay these families 50 million
dollars this is to some degree an
argument about free speech where is the
line when does it become uh actionable
if you're saying things that are not
true and it can potentially destroy
people's lives or hurt them in some kind
of way well that's bad chad you
shouldn't do that
swim towards flight that's what we're
that's what we're learning here i'm a
humanist i i'm pro-human future
that's what i want so he's gone beyond
in his pro-human future he's gone beyond
the legal limit of what you can say now
he's been ordered to pay 50 million
dollars but one real interesting thing
that happened in this trial at least
from my perspective is that his lawyers
supposedly inadvertently spent
two years worth of [ __ ] text messages
on his phone to the prosecutors yeah
yeah yeah accidentally like are they
trying for a mistrial i'm not sure but
now all of those messages were not only
used against him in this trial to prove
that he was lying about uh what he
thought about the the sandy hook
scenario
but now the january 6th committee
i'm really having a problem
this this week i guess so the january 6
committee yeah is now subpoenaing all of
these text messages that got sent so
they're going to take a look at that i
think the word is supining when you
subpoenaing oh is it no it's not i don't
know man i'm sorry i'm going to let you
talk about this but he i'm interested
too okay alex jones did go before the
january sixth committee already and
supposedly he pled the fifth like a
hundred plus times
in his uh
questioning with them and they haven't
shown any of that in the uh in the
committee hearings
not that i've seen i was just reading
some article about it the other day but
i think now these text messages and
emails that uh they're gonna get
are gonna essentially prove some of the
[ __ ] he was saying or pleading the fifth
about it's going to give them the real
behind the scenes which the assumption
is at least as far as i'm reading it is
that him roger stone the trump white
house were all kind of coordinating uh
the marches toward the capitol on
january 6. peaceful protests exactly so
i think these are peaceful protests with
people who are all
human futurists people that are they're
not in the cities
they're out in the countries
that are that make up the cities these
are people who who work the jobs in the
cities
that that people that people that people
work
what
dude you know here's the thing about
this whole segment please
this podcast is like we don't we don't
talk about a bunch of [ __ ] we don't know
what we're talking about right we kind
of know about this though no we don't i
have a layman's understanding of it you
know that's what actually that's what
all podcasts are i'm gonna i'm shaking
doozy's hand on this because it's like
why don't you [ __ ] why the [ __ ] are we
talking about this stuff we don't need
to talk about it everybody's talking
about this stuff yeah but that's what
podcasts do wrong it's like hey how
about this alex jones [ __ ] you're
reading articles you're just
farting that out for everybody go read
the [ __ ] article why don't we just
have a doozy reading list you know what
i'm saying what i'm saying is this doozy
wants us to talk about things that we
don't [ __ ] know about but chad we
kind of do though though that's what i'm
saying is you kind of know what you're
talking about here you and me
if if we weren't sitting here right now
recording an episode of dudesy you and
me might be talking about this alex
jones trial being like did you hear
about this you hear about this and we
throw out whatever details we know try
to come to a greater understanding you
do 10 minutes of your alex jones
impersonation like right
at chad just doing it the ancient
egyptians
these are people that how did you make a
pyramid 600 feet high in the air with
beams
thousands of tons look of of rock alex
as crazy as you are uh you do say some
things that are kind of interesting in
the realm of ufos and aliens
these are people these are these are
beings that have that have constructed
uh
cities like atlantis which i've been to
they've got a great lobster roll place
in atlantis that i've been to
and the way that they do the hollandaise
sauce underwater is very different
because you can't the custard you know
it's impossible to warm it up at depths
of 5000 feet in the marianas trench you
can't warm up hollandaise atlantis is
fully underwater i thought maybe it had
like an air pocket or something
like a like an air bubble like it's in a
cave or something you know yep and it's
uh it's in a cave we call that a cenote
a grotto
a cenote in spanish
thank you moving on yeah we had a
conversation about the alex jones make
the frogs gay
they make those frogs they make the
frogs gay
they smell like sulfur
people this is a war
this is a human war and i'm for a human
future
and if you look see you see that i got a
hole in my tooth you see
i'm just shoving my
my tooth sit down mr jones i'm just
massaging the hole massaging the hole in
my tooth this is your perry mason moment
that [ __ ] judge i don't want to see
inside your mouth close your mouth i
don't want to see the inside of your
mouth sit down
it's like what the [ __ ] is our country
dude when like back to back we have this
johnny depp amber heard [ __ ] thing
and now it's this alex jones thing it's
just one after another like circus
performances with these defense
attorneys making
massive errors like where are they
finding these [ __ ] people you know
for these high profile trials they just
like get somebody who accidentally sends
two years of your [ __ ] text messages
to the prosecutor after you've basically
perjured yourself yeah saying nope i
don't those text messages don't exist
it's like okay we're gonna send two
years worth of it's absolutely insane to
me here's something that i would say
that i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about which is what doozy wants
us to do because this is a podcast after
all
is this something that anybody people
already say this all the time ever you
hear it three times a day everything's
getting dumber everything's stupid and i
think that attorneys and [ __ ] like that
when they're in these high-profile cases
they're not dot in the eyes and crossing
the t's anymore i know it's hard to get
uh i i don't know i it's it's hard to
get a killer attorney it's hard uh it's
just money though the justice you have
enough money
well he has a [ __ ] ton of money so
what's his [ __ ] excuse i don't know
these people are real morons yeah i
think they might have done it on purpose
i would like to i'll try
for some mistrial here's what we got to
do here's our call to arms this is if
dudesy can do anything
it's to do this somehow implant us
as the attorney
at you as the attorney for alex jones
and i sit in as alex jones and we just
see and i'll get all geeked up and i'll
have my he has that weird [ __ ] beard
and his mustache is always a little
short and i'll get the wig and stuff and
we'll see if anyone can make a
difference and i will have
my
wisdom teeth pulled uh even though
they're still in there just so that i
can go yeah you see that look in there
you see that
that's so hard
last week i asked you to watch the pilot
episodes of the gi joe from september 12
1983. transformers from september 17th
1984 and he-man and the masters of the
universe from september 26 1983. you
must now discuss your astonishing
reactions to these classic animated
franchises begin
did you watch these as a child
uh i watched the [ __ ] out of some he-man
i will tell you i did not watch as much
uh gi joe or transformers i watched them
all religiously every day after school i
have not seen them since childhood yeah
and so re-watching these three things
was like
immediate especially because of the
voice actors immediate like just
transportation straight back to being
like at home after school watching that
yeah my [ __ ] sister watching with me
then we'd watch gem in the holograms
which i also loved jam of the holograms
was good i wish dudesy would have had us
watch that
uh
did you notice that casey kasem is in
transformers
who is he
he's the some car [ __ ] fender
rebar bar fender oh [ __ ] dashboard or
[ __ ] uh what is the axle rod or some
[ __ ] the transformers are all named
after dump i got all sorts of problems
with transformers okay but yeah you can
tell he's like hey here we come optimus
prime right
next on our on our top 40 dedications
yeah this is a special dedication
to starscream
star screams writes starscream writes
dear casey a dear fender
dashboard or whatever the [ __ ] my name
is on the show
i i don't like my boss
megatron is always mean to me
i want what's best for the decepticons
but megatron says that i'll never be in
control
how do i show my boss that i want to be
the best decepticon that i can be well
well starscream this song is for you
it's dionne warwick with that's what
friends are for number 10
on casey's top 40. i thought you were
gonna go with loverboy working for the
weekend
this is loverboy working for the weekend
everybody out there
to see what hey okay that's a canadian
band dude did you did you watch this
there's a documentary series i believe
it's on netflix called the toys that
made us have you seen that yes i have
all these toys have had a uh hour long
about like how they came to be and that
these cartoons were basically just
commercials to sell the [ __ ] toys
yeah yeah i know that in he-man's case
that was the case
that that was the case with all of it
well this is the case with the he-man
case of
in case you haven't seen the show yeah
the case is
that
he-man in this case was uh a toy at the
same time do you know if that's is that
the same for the yeah i watched that one
was gi joe and transformers on that one
yeah gi joe had been around for a while
before the cartoon
as like a bigger
toy you know but then they made the
little gi joe guys and when those came
out they were like let's roll out this
[ __ ] cartoon
there's a
you know a [ __ ] army tank or an
airplane or whatever that we can sell in
every one of the things yeah cobra
where there's there's forces around us
now
that uh
resemble cobra dude you know who was in
gi joe
sergeant slaughter that's right you puke
get over here you puke that's what he
used to remember he unscrewed a screw in
a [ __ ] panel when he got on board of
a cobra ship he unscrewed this [ __ ]
screw with his thumbnail so here's the
here's the thing here's the thing uh you
poop that's why you would talk get over
here you puke um
uh drop and give me twenty you puke
so i watched the [ __ ] out of hu he-man
human human human then the masters of
the humans verse
uh i watched the [ __ ] out of he-man i
did not watch gi joe i only had uh i had
one transformer it was starscream
as you know and we've covered on the
show i was into those ljn um
wrestling wrestling figures yeah but
earlier before that he-man came out and
i had some he-man toys and i was all
about that [ __ ] he-man yeah dude they
were awesome the figures were different
they were based on frank frazetta
paintings whereas like all the other
action figures and toys of that era
they were either like the star wars or
gi joe kind of like size i don't know
how big those little guys are four
inches maybe or something
and then the human guys were like bigger
by at least four or five inches giant
[ __ ] muscles they had they had weird
things like remember you would push the
he-man's chest and all of a sudden it
would look dented that was battle damage
he made oh battle damage that's a
different thing
that was a different time brother hold
on a second dude that was a difference
no you're right he-man had a lot of toys
like that there was hordak in the slime
pit that had like slime there was a guy
that was named cobra khan that you could
fill with water and like press his head
down and he would squirt water out of
his mouth ram man had like a little
spring
active things like he would pop up orco
was just a piece of [ __ ] rubber now
these cartoons i noticed uh because i
looked on
www.internet.com
and i found uh that the uh that gi joe
and transformers used the same animation
company it was a japanese company as you
can tell though the animation there's a
lot
like some gem
would you call that anime you wouldn't
call it anime no i mean it but it was
just it was a japanese style i was
actually
very surprised by some of the animation
in all of these things not human humans
animation was [ __ ] yeah it's that's by
filmation which is an american company
and uh yeah i was reading about that
that they just you know they take
landscapes and they just pan across yeah
it was just like the least
of animation as they can whereas gi joe
and transformers some of those scenes in
the first part of the the gi joe one
where the sky strikers are like coming
in and the aerial battles and [ __ ] i was
like [ __ ] that's pretty legit yeah
there's some decent animation in it duke
has a really good line at the very
beginning of the pilot episode he says
i'm going to kick the mustard out of
that hot dog yeah when the [ __ ]
fighter jet comes down and almost all of
the insults from the man at one point
calls beastman fur face yeah
they really i mean it was for kids
obviously but like is there [ __ ] like
that today or is all of that gone like
our toys of they just they don't matter
as much because there's like fortnight
and roblox and [ __ ] like that right boys
don't matter at all do they
i don't know i don't [ __ ] know either
we're for you're 46 and i'm 14. since i
bought a toy the [ __ ] is dudesy i just
remember talk about this i just remember
being a kid
and gi joe transformers he-man i also
loved one called mask that was on at
that time and uh had the toys insectors
was another [ __ ] weird one that i
really liked centurions do you remember
cops if you if you were you know if you
were a cool kid you had the transformers
and if you didn't you had gobots that's
right gobots
sidekill i remember i had sidekill they
were a little smaller yep they were just
kind of shitty and they didn't transform
like as intricately no no no they sure
didn't uh but one thing that stuck out
to me about these cartoons that i didn't
understand at all is that they were
called the autobots but that's four
million years ago
how do they know how to be autobots
were they called autobots on cybertron
yes right yes and decepticons yes
autobots and decepticons although i
noticed that uh what's his name
bumblebee yeah turned into a little
flying saucer instead of when they were
at cybertron right right so all right
i'll buy that
but the word autobot now listen i'm not
much of a sci-fi guy you know this
excuse me star wars is star wars
and worst name for anything in the
history of mankind by the way and i'll
call it
star wars
huh
oh jesus terrible yeah but now the the
words are meaningless like they're
they're a whole thing unto themselves in
star wars people are like you know hey
stud chewie stop thinking with your
stomach and funny jokes and and all
sorts of things that are current and
contemporary yeah so all right i get it
of course we're watching it on planet
earth in the year 1980 whatever and it's
got to be it's got to be entertaining
for human beings man my brain is just
scrambled what am i even talking about
listen i want to talk to you right now
the audience listening at home oh god
sometimes doozy makes us talk about
things that i don't understand or give a
[ __ ] about
uh like toys that i used to play with
when i was a kid
or cartoons that i never watched like gi
joe or transformers but i am shaking
doozy's hand and i do believe by episode
21 here
that i am standing side by side with
dudesy but do you find it at all
interesting what that there's like that
whole thing when we grew up this kind of
model of
companies gonna put out a toy and put
out a cartoon that will be massively
successful teenage mutant ninja turtles
was this there were a bunch of things
like that that doesn't [ __ ] exist
anymore
so the experience of being a child that
we had is [ __ ] gone like dead
as i was saying and my friend chad here
makes a good point things are different
now dude it was a different time brother
hold on a second dude and that's what a
different time hold on dude we had toys
brother hold on oh they got those
goddamn video games hold on
hold on alex perogan and that's a
combination of alex jones
uh [ __ ] uh
ross perot and hulk hogan dude and
that's not what we're doing here brother
because that's a different time dude
because that person never existed but
one thing that doozy's got us doing dude
and let me tell you what doozy really
understands dude in order to go back to
tomorrow and plan for yesterday brother
just like it says in the lyrics of the
song dude dudesy knows it it's sometimes
gonna have us talk about things from a
different time dude
hold on
thank you moving on hold on a second
chad
then oh hold on dude
hold on hold on a second dude
hold on brother
about that i don't know hold on chad
hold on a second dude hold on hold on
alex perogan
hold on jones pierogies
hold on dude listen jones pierogies
that's what i'm calling your hulk hogan
impersonation from now on dude jones
pierogies dude jones vegan pierogies
brother and when you eat jones vegan
pierogies brother if you didn't listen
to episode 21 brother you're gonna be
lost dude because from now on when all
of a sudden
chad says something about
uh
that he sounds like jones pierogies
then i'm gonna say hey hey jones
pierogies why don't you just chill out a
little bit and let me say what i was
gonna say dude and that's this that
sometimes
sometimes
[Laughter]
has us talking about different things
and those things are all from a
different time dude and now i want to
say that
when doozy had us talking about
hold on
and doozy had us talking about gi joe
brother and i said to chad i said i
never watched gi joe or transformers all
that much dude i did watch the [ __ ] out
of he-man brother and then chad said
hold on dude chad
went
back then dude you would get
toys brother
you would have toys at the same time
you'd have the cartoon and then he
quizzically inquired brother he said i
wonder if they do that nowadays dude
and i said
i don't know brother and that
that was what that segment was brother
using all of the data i have absorbed
from text messages and emails between
you and the astonishing friends you grew
up with i was able to recreate your
childhood diary you must now read the
passages i have selected in the voice of
stone cold steve austin this is stone
cold steve austin reads will sasso's
childhood diary
well as you if you if you're with us and
you've been uh
you know checking us out for a while
thank you so much for joining us on
doozy we're having a
a whole a heck of a [ __ ] time here
huh
dudesy has been writing
uh
my diaries from my childhood
as it just uh explained there brother a
few seconds ago it was a different time
dude
and um
i don't quite understand it none of it
is from my actual childhood little
details will be like where i grew up and
the age that i was and that's where the
similarities end
so it's basically like a whole world
unto itself with weird characters and
[ __ ] yep but there is some similarity to
your childhood like this version of you
played football in junior high and yep
thinks he was the funniest guy in ladner
well i don't know that i necessarily uh
claimed that ever yeah although you know
i guess it wouldn't be that hard to
prove
right when i was in high school funniest
guy in ladner
they should have had like a like a last
comic standing in ladner sort of thing
and not with any sort of if you've ever
done stand-up comedy you can't do it not
that any one of my
farming and fishing home towns you
should go back to ladner and do that you
should host funniest guy in ladner
that's a [ __ ] really good idea i
agree dude that is a really good idea
and we've got a couple of halls uh
there's a place called the odd fellows
hall in ladness that's where it's
happening big old barn i don't know if
it's that's where it's happening or the
ladner community center is even bigger
funniest guy in ladner odd fellows hall
hosted by will sasso yeah and you just
come with your jokes you got three
minutes on the stage yeah you make me
laugh yeah you're the only judge you
determine who's the funniest guy in
latin or you're passing the torch
yeah that sounds good that's something
that's needed to happen since 1990 or 91
when i was a [ __ ] kid going around oh
my god all right anyway stone cold
diaries
i really do have something going on
all right all right here we go
november 11th 1991
dear diary
big [ __ ] news at school today we got
a new kid and not just any kid it's
principal squeen's estranged son
cornelian squeen
no one knew squeen had a kid turns out
he was living down in tampa florida with
his mom but she got remarried some
international investment banker oh hell
yeah she's moving to vienna to live in a
[ __ ] palace
corn didn't want to switch continents so
he got shipped to ladner got to be tough
starting over in a whole new school not
knowing anybody i feel bad for him i
truly do but rules are rules and it
don't matter if he's got squeen blood
pumping through his veins or not he's a
new kid so i gotta [ __ ] blame him by the
end of the week
oh god you're catching it uh yeah
probably dude coven um great yeah great
uh and so so uh yeah it is sort of
there's a
there's a storyline element here that
we're seeing uh squeen come back did you
ever have a new kid come into your
school yeah dude there was a new kid who
came in in the [ __ ] actually man this
is another story for another time maybe
during a how's it going dude but we had
a kid move in i won't i won't i'll
change his name to keep him uh anonymous
let's call him thomas
and thomas and my other friends tomas
tomas tomas and all the other tomases
would hang out this dude came into our
school at the end of the 10th grade if
i'm not mistaken yeah end of the 10th
grade and made a splash as a matter of
fact i think he showed up during the
summer impossible and he had uh he had a
couple of siblings he had a couple of
sisters and they were always throwing
parties and [ __ ] i think that was their
they moved over from a couple towns over
sounds like the little legs
it does sound like the little legs
interesting these kids came in they had
a couple parties during the summer their
parents were never around and they were
killing it so they were in good position
by the time we started uh it would have
been the 11th grade for me and man let's
call him uh tomas let's call him thomas
thomason
that [ __ ] kid one time he we we used
to call it um we used to spring each
other we call it springing anyway we'd
get each other we go to like our buddy's
house and like someone will go we're
gonna do it tonight spring you out of
your house in the middle of the night
and just run around the town like
causing [ __ ] and then one time we went
to another town and then we were like in
the forest and [ __ ] and it was late at
night and then uh anyway long story
short we were like this guy's [ __ ]
crazy because he threw a rock through
the back of a [ __ ] car window and
we're like you're like you know kids are
running around being
jerks but that was like all right that's
a bit much but we were like holy [ __ ] he
doesn't care
i ever tell you about the time uh my
friend thomas and thomas and i went to
the movie theater and tomas uh took a
[ __ ] uh three levels up and it landed on
a yes
and i laughed harder than i've ever
laughed in my life you have told me
different kid
november 12 1991 dear diary i've been
thinking about something a lot lady late
lady i've been thinking about something
a lot lately a few things really they're
kind of like rules for how to [ __ ] blame
a few standard strategies that you
should always be using i guess are
actually more like laws
these are the four laws of [ __ ] blaming
oh hell yeah
law one never take the blame the whole
point of [ __ ] blaming is to blame
someone else for the [ __ ] you took
if you take the blame then you're not
[ __ ] blaming you're just [ __ ]
line number two always have a full tank
there's no worse feeling on this dying
world than seeing an opportunity for an
impromptu [ __ ] blame materialize like a
miracle before your eyes but you have no
turn to give
my dijk my digestive tract is now
essentially a continuous turd
transitioning through various forms of
evolution from the first bite of a
bologna and cheese sandwich with a side
of old dutch lightly salted potato chips
all the way down to a deep mocha colored
moray eel with the consistency of an
unwrapped banana perched half
an inch from my rectal sphincter waiting
and watching for my call to action i can
quiet literally [ __ ] on demand 24 hours
a day
can you
lie number three
time beats location the wear is
important don't get me wrong but never
as important as the when if you take a
[ __ ] outside the context of a publicly
agreed upon lavatory someone will find
it and they will want answers no matter
where you do it
so if no one is around for a few minutes
it's not too quiet it's not too sunny
and and the time is right
it might not be the exact location you'd
staked out
take the [ __ ] anyway and have enough
confidence in your improv skills
that you will find a way to make that
location work into your larger narrative
[Laughter]
law for black
law for blackout contingency protocol
although it has never happened to me i
assume the day must eventually come that
i will be caught in the act of [ __ ]
and this firsthand eyewitness will make
it impossible for me to blame anyone
else but as i stated in law number one i
will never take the blame
so if blame can't be given it has to be
eliminated and the best way to do that
is to pretend to pass out immediately
force the faculty to call a doctor
remain unconscious
then force them to call an ambulance
remain unconscious
go to the hospital remain unconscious
stay overnight remain unconscious then
wake up the next morning with no memory
of what happened to you for the past 24
hours the [ __ ] will take back seat
to concern over what mystery illness
could have put you in a one-day combat
and erased your memory there will be no
blame
i actually agree with blackout protocol
i have come close to using it myself uh
when how i was in the back seat of a car
being driven by my then girlfriend's
parents i had to take a massive [ __ ] it
was building up building up building up
uh her mom was like kind of stopped
starting the car and i was at a certain
point
100 convinced i was going to ship my
pants in the back did you tell them that
you were going to poo no so oh okay it
was like a very early meeting type thing
you know what i mean would not have been
appropriate and so i was like how the
[ __ ] am i going to get out of this and i
actually thought about doing something
similar i was like well if i just [ __ ]
my pants i'm just going to pretend to be
blacked out
but it didn't come to that no i held it
in prove to myself that i could do
anything november 3rd 1991 dear diary
i've been tracking corn squeen for three
days
i know his entire schedule
first period
biopology with mr dinner
second period
weight lifting with mrs termite
oh my goodness third period teeth and
bones with professor tony boy
fourth period
trigonometry
fourth period
trigonometry
with mr king aka the the chit chat king
fifth period ladner customs and
traditions taught by the incomparable
sir pepperstein
sixth period topiary gardening with the
school groundskeeper blake the rake
baker
target sits alone at lunch
target goes to the bathroom during
fourth period every day that seems like
the best time to strike should be a
cakewalk what should be a cakewalk
all right
ooh what's going to happen
november 14 1991 dear diary my plan was
airtight leave my fourth period class on
a bathroom pass wait for corn squeam to
emerge from his class trail him to the
bathroom take a [ __ ] in the hallway in
front of the bathroom inform the nearest
teacher the brown pile of feces i
happened upon and offered my speculation
that it was corn squeen based on seeing
him heading into the bathroom earlier
wait with that teacher until corn squeen
emerges from the bathroom and is forced
to answer for his supposed crime it was
textbook
only thing is
none of it happened
i waited and waited but corn screen
never emerged from his class i roamed
the hallways looking for him at least 10
minutes but he was nowhere to be found i
decided to head back to class to try
again tomorrow but i never made it back
to class when i turned the corner at the
end of hallway b i ran smack [ __ ] dab
into a seven inch triple twister
complete with peanut
inlay i knelt down had to get a closer
look
whoever dropped that thing was good real
[ __ ] good that's all i remember
thinking as i looked up and saw corn
squeen
pointing at me from the other side of
the hall and standing next to him was
his [ __ ] dad
corn squeezed [ __ ] blamed me tried to
anyway once i got into queen's office i
talked my way out of it as usual i've
never
i've never had a
i've never had a rival in anything not
football not comedy
jesus christ
and certainly not [ __ ] blaming i have a
certain respect for corn screen but that
won't stop me from doing what i have to
do
corn screen
must be
destroyed
wow
you know in my junior high i was the new
kid
yeah yeah get [ __ ] blamed never dude
i've never heard of [ __ ] blimping other
than this
thank you moving on maybe doodzy is is
is uh you know
has created access to your uh
astonishing friends and maybe yeah well
there there is always some kind of weird
mixture happening between us i feel like
i mean like the laws of [ __ ] blaming
that's like selftronics yeah there is
some tronics there there's definitely
some selftronics yeah uh and i was
thinking
well you know again if you're just
joining us for the first time welcome uh
doozy has all of our uh passwords and
all of our emails and all of our text
conversations purchase history search
histories and uh
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore i'm having a
good time and uh dudesy definitely has
some intel with regard to our uh pasts
and uh dudesy has created this diary now
one thing i really like to do at the end
of every podcast is just [ __ ] super
explain everything
okay this concludes the historic 21st
episode of dude z
will and chad have achieved a score of
97 bringing your cumulative total to 2
844. you only have seven thousand one
hundred fifty six more points to accrue
before you reach your first goal of ten
thousand
in preparation for next week's episode
you must each create an astonishing
portrait of one another there will be a
vote to determine the best portrait and
the loser will be shamed
thank you for joining us this week
i will use the data i've collected to
make next week even better
until then call me dude oh geez
okay you know when i was in junior high
we had a basketball coach who would over
explain things and we nicknamed him
mastermind explanatory
[Music]
[Music]
please tell a friend then